[Music]
almost
all hard problems are solved by teams
and the reason is if it's a hard problem
for one thing it's going to have a
number of aspects and nobody
nobody today can be an expert in all of
them
so we get specialists and then we get
sub specialists and so forth so the
first thing the project manager is
probably going to do is decompose the
big
ugly hard problem that he or she faces
and divide it into a bunch of
sub-problems and then
have different specialists work on the
sub-problems this is where cognitive
diversity comes in
people trained in different toolkits
they're accustomed to looking at
problems in different ways
and then the team
becomes more reliable working on this
hard problem
than any of its parts scott page who's
professor of political science and
economics at the university of michigan
wrote in a book called the difference
which was sort of a summary of his years
of work
a slogan the slogan is diversity
trump's ability which is very
counter-intuitive
because normally managers say i want to
hire the most stable person for this
problem
so scott paige and i together wrote this
this paper
in which we explain to people that
of course ability matters and diversity
doesn't trump
ability is an effort to get more nuance
into this trade-off between diversity
and relevance
we're asking project managers to do
something that's
mentally somewhat challenging which is
to think about the trade-off between
ability and diversity when is
shareability more important when is
diversity more important
when are maybe both important
if you can figure out ways of
integrating them
then you're probably going to wind up
with hiring strategies that are much
better
than if you focus on one or the other
alone if a project manager is
hiring people from the same specialty
the top specialist
then basically he or she is putting all
his his or her eggs in one basket
and that means the person hasn't faced
up to the harsh realities of working on
hard problems which
is even the best approach can fail
that's exactly why
portfolio diversification is recommended
by finance
experts for the sa to hedge against
uncertainty
our kind of analysis what we're working
on has
implications for all fields because
remember humans are the problem solvers
power excellence on this planet
the young people i see are fantastic
they're much better than my generation
my generation was fine it was good but
this generation is much better
and it's really important because we
face really tough problems like climate
change
i am a complete optimist about human
beings yeah we're imperfect and
we're not as smart as we think we are
but we are really clever problem solvers
that's what humans do we just keep
improving and i don't see any limit to
[Music]
that